[Applause]
welcome everybody to another down the
middle um
i have always had a huge interest in
demographics and i cannot tell you how
much we
are about to learn from one dennis
mcgill he's director of research and
co-founded zellman associates you may
recall a few months back uh we had it
down the middle with ivy zellman
they're equally brilliant when it comes
to the housing market but but dennis has
just published an analysis a study
called cradle to grave let's face it we
have a people problem
before we go there though um i wanna i
wanna take dennis back to
uh kind of how he met ivy
and how she influenced uh his
perspective shall we say on the work
ethic
yeah well thank you for having me
danielle this is fun i look forward to
talking about it and
not that many people will uh either
admit or be truthful about enjoying
demographics it's uh as you know
probably can be pretty boring topic
pretty slow moving topics so not front
page material but
in the world of housing obviously
matters quite a bit
um
yeah so the the funny backstory or
history with ivy and i is we've worked
together for over 20 years um we've
never worked in the same city she's
always been in cleveland as long as i've
known her i've always been in new york
and i actually started working on her
team as an intern
i was in between my undergrad and
graduate programs at michigan and
i didn't have a whole lot of insight on
what i was going to do it was pretty
naive about the whole thing and lucked
into a internship for this analyst
working in cleveland and i was at school
of michigan from detroit so you know was
familiar with the cleveland area and
thought it kind of strange at a wall
street analyst very successful and
worked there but that's probably the way
i was able to get the
uh job offer sure and then
request a
full-time offer back to credit suisse
and
she requested he brought back to her
team and
my only stipulation was i would have to
work in new york and not cleveland and
then
this rest is history we've been
partnering together since and
i had a lot of great mentors on the team
early on and then as people started to
depart and i became sort of this whole
senior member and we grew
from there
and um tell me about sunday not being
fun day
yeah one of my my earliest memories of
iv i i don't even know if she
interviewed me for the job so i probably
didn't meet her until
after i'd done a few weeks of work in
new york and then the rest of the summer
was in cleveland and i was always in the
office late in new york even it's just
it was the mentality of the team it was
a lot to get done and so i carried that
over to cleveland and would often work
on the weekends as well and i remember
being in all day on a saturday and then
thinking well sunday could be a day
where i could just regroup and i got a
call probably around four or five
o'clock on sunday from her uh you know
fairly high right voice wondering where
i was and why i wasn't at the office um
and she placed the same call to the
other associates as well so it must have
been a bad weekend for some some reason
that sunday is not a day off and it is
uh you want to succeed in this industry
you got to work hard you got to work
hard especially when you're young and
certainly stuck with me um i think there
was always an ambition to be there and
be working pretty diligently
even when you're not expected to be but
i think it kind of anchored that even
more to know that if you want to be
successful in a tough industry with a
lot of smart people
the easiest thing you can control is
effort and that's one way you can
differentiate yourself early on and that
was a clear message i got that's a great
philosophy um
speaking of effort i have to ask a
little bit of background because
uh
it took me a very long time
to get through this massive analysis
that you have just published how long
did it take you to put this together
yeah
well we actually so we started um back
when we were credit suisse we actually
didn't do much demographic work on our
own um we had a good relationship joint
center harvard they do a lot of
tremendous work on demographics and a
lot of times we would just sort of
ingest that into our process and it
wasn't until we started zombie
associates in 07
and we started to expand into other
areas and one of the areas we got into
shortly after starting the term was
multi-family
and the whole point of covering
multi-family was well we're already
doing all this work on residential and
we understand how it's in a high level
but if we're going to cover multi-family
apartments then we really need to
understand what determines whether
someone lives in a single family home or
an apartment so that sent me down the
path of trying to figure that out and
ultimately that was more of a
demographic type question so as i got
more familiar with all the demographic
data that was out there and started
trying to lay out a lot of this what
actually dropped out of the middle of it
was single family win for rent which at
that time nobody spoke about this was in
2011. nobody's talking about single
family rental it was before invitation
homes comes from the two biggest in the
country uh it's on the single family
reid side had even bought a house
and it was part of a report we published
called leasing american dream
which at that time you were seeing
tremendous amount of foreclosed
homeowners essentially just re-rent in
their state neighborhoods
and you realize that it was already a
massive part of the housing stock which
nobody ever thought about it was always
buy a house rent an apartment that's the
perception so that's where it all
started and then we published another
report in 2013 called coil demographic
spring which is where we really took the
effort of forecasting a lot of this
stuff on our own starting with
population age-based type analyses and
extending that to housing and doing it
in a way where it wasn't just high-level
forecasts but
understanding how people live and why
they live that way and trying to
understand it granularly at the age
level are they living alone are they
living as a married couple as roommates
etc because once you know that
you can actually predict much easier
whether they're going to be in a single
family home
and from that point on um there was
always an idea of well this would be a
continuous process of updating that
long-term thought around demographics
and i actually have a notepad that i
update my to-do list on every single
week and once i put something on there
it doesn't come off until it's done
and you'd probably laugh at this but
i've had this demographic report on my
to-do list since 2015. oh my gosh
and it was always a process of updating
uh you know the data and thinking about
the process and doing a lot with uh
getting this the infrastructure in place
but there were always other things and
other things that became priorities and
it was sort of this building process but
it wasn't necessarily getting to a
report stage and the pandemics were
really accelerated as a priority for me
because so many things changed with how
people were living and how quickly and
when they moved and the topics became
much more prominent
in the media and then around wall street
where people are trying to think out
think about where we are in the cycle so
it kind of became one of those things
say okay this is now the priority we're
gonna start um and get this thing done
and so really probably for the last six
or nine months prior to publishing it
was my main priority um the first time i
was able to really get back into it uh
but it helped that i was sort of
building those blocks incrementally
slowly over the years sure and uh
crossed that one off to the to-do list
after being there for six years
well um so so i i'm gonna i'm gonna
actually throw a name out there that you
probably won't recognize when i when i
started at dlj in new york
uh an economist by the name of dick
hopkinson was uh was at dlj and
demographics was all he did and he was
completely disregarded because they were
like this is never going to happen
um but again this was back in in the mid
1990s my question is
we have a people problem apparently
how long has this people problem been
building up
within the united states
well really it's when you look at the
growth rates so the growth rate of the
population this last decade is people
have probably seen 7.4
that was the slowest for any decade
other than the 30s and 30s was 7.3 so
there was a decent shot this was going
to be the slowest decade ever but it's
not that much slower than what we've
seen the last couple decades a few
hundred basis points um but it's on that
trajectory that
it's it's now is about the time you have
to start doing a little bit of a wake-up
call on it because when you
appreciate how important the baby
boomers were and they were forming their
household years and then they've
obviously been around since and the
leading edge of the baby boomers is
still in a very healthy age but that's
starting to get into more of a tipping
point
and along the way you've had other
things happening among how young adults
are living and fertility rates which we
can talk about but you're getting to the
point where the aging of the population
is options and so for this current
decade we actually forecast four percent
uh population growth which is obviously
going to be the lowest ever and by the
end of the decade a lot of this hinges
on immigration obviously um
domestically you say the organic
births versus deaths will tip into
negative territory by the end of this
decade we think and that'll be the first
time ever but that'll be the case um as
you have the older generation
just magnitude of it certainly improved
life expectancy but the magnitude of the
generation will lead to more deaths than
we're seeing on the younger end of the
first so immigration will be the only
way
that will be driving the population
growth once you get past this decade
which brings about a lot of different
conversations about how you want to
think about immigration
um but i think that's the wake up call
is that
you don't have this persistent growth
backdrop that's been part of the country
and part of housing for the last 100
years basically so you've used the word
growth about 10 times in the last three
minutes um
so if if i understand you correctly and
i think that this is a critical
distinction that a lot of people don't
make
size does not matter
when you're discussing populations
right
yeah and particularly with housing and
it depends which part of housing you
want to think about if you were
trying to figure out how many home sales
there were in the country or should be
over time then the size of the
population the number of households and
certainly the age of those households
since older people who lesser even like
younger people would be the way you
would approach that would start from
the capacity if you will
but when you're talking about new
construction needs and incremental
growth um too often those things are
mixed so when you are comparing housing
starts to population you're comparing a
flow to a static base
and what you really have to think about
if you want to think about housing
starts with new home construction supply
you have to think about that flow versus
the flow of the demand side which
indirectly is population but more
directly it's households so it's the
change in households that drives new
construction those are the two clothes
that need to match up
and you'll see particularly with a lot
of the research that's being done
by third parties now or other analysts
you'll see a lot of comparisons of
starts to population i've seen it in
the mainstream media i've seen it with
relatively smart clients or
analysts to say well look at how many
starts there are per pocket per person
and they look at through time where they
look at
1970 the population is x today we're
significantly larger than that but we're
building fewer homes than we were in the
70s i don't use that as justification to
say the system's growth we can't bring
housing supply to market because of all
these different factors and therefore we
need to build more we need to figure out
ways how to build build build and it's
just a mathematical
inconsistency i call it mathematical
insanity when you compare comparing
those two numbers
um
so
so things have been slowing down
for a few decades
uh
and we'll get into the nitty-gritty of
the flows in and out of of population
growth
but how did the pandemic
obviously it expedited the need for you
to delve deeply into this subject uh but
how
well now let me back up how did the
2009-2010 recession
affect
the growth of households let's ask that
question first
yeah
it's a good way to start it because that
was um that report i mentioned 2013 that
first really deep dive we made on this
topic and had a lot of our own
proprietary forecasts out there was
coming on heels of that data so
decennial 10 census data had been
released they had a lot of granularity
just come out of the great recession we
were at that point pretty optimistic
about the housing recovery it was in
early 2012 that we said okay this is
kind of our official flip of we think
the recovery started
and that was this i think you can still
say this current recovery
um and so you had a lot of great
information work from and what you had
to decipher was how much of this is
cyclical and how much is secular because
you had obviously very high unemployment
rates especially among young adults
so it didn't impact the population side
per se other than probably depressing
birth rates at that time relative to
where they were fertility rates
but it had a lot of impact on how people
were living because of the financial
circumstances
both informing households particularly
on young adults who they didn't have a
job obviously there's a lot of
pushback on their ability to be
independent and on their own which means
you have a lot more young adults living
at home which is destructive for housing
demand
and then how they live within the
ecosystem multi-family to single family
so you had excessive single family
dwelling during that period because
anybody who wanted a mortgage could get
a mortgage and you pulled a lot of
people in a single family that probably
couldn't really afford it and the
recession not only gutted the demand
side the employment truck backdrop but
of course a lot of people that we're in
single family to probably either
decouple back down to multi-family or
back into friends or families homes so
as we were forming the outlook for this
decade one of the big assumptions we
made was that double up factor the young
adults living at home
which was far higher than any other
period
we previously had seen would reverse and
that would be a tailwind on top of
normal demographics if they unbundle
yeah that's i mean there was a lot of
talk about they're going to move out of
their parents basement i mean that was
kind of it was that was kind of the
thing the cliche the the
the millennials are going to move out of
their parents basement it's going to
cause a huge housing boom yeah and and
when you look at the data historically
for those age cohorts and we tended to
to break it out into 18 and 19 and then
every five years thereafter every cohort
had a bundle of headwind
so it was universal across some adults
but if you looked at the history of it
you'd say there's every reason to
believe that should be a tailwind and an
unbundling as dire as that great
recession was on those unemployment
rates you didn't have another period
where you could look at it being so high
for so long so there was every
expectation on our side that that would
turn around that was part that was part
of the reason it was called oil
democratic spring because we feel like
you had
that aging of the millennials plus you
had the young adults kind of reversing
out of the cycle
and the uh one of the
more puzzling things throughout the
decade in this we're tracking this every
year is that it actually went the other
way young adults at home is higher in
2020 than it was in 2010
which is mind-blowing when you think
about
the cyclical headwind in the economic
evidence happening in 2010 and just
to go over that period is quite quite
surprising
so just to contextualize it if you will
just round numbers where were we in 2010
versus where we were in 2020
yes i think if i'm remembering correctly
2010 was probably around 20
and i think prior to that age adjusted
you were probably closer to 16 17
16 17 historically
and i want to say it was probably
another 200 basis points or so this
decade 2020 versus 2010
um so fairly material especially kind of
normalized for the age cohorts and and
it was a it was a it was a dynamic that
was playing out throughout the decade it
was every year you were kind of seeing
an inch a little bit higher and as you
got further and further away from 2010
you didn't have that same excuse of well
the young adults were impaired by the
great great recession i i do think
that there was a that cohort that was
impaired was probably permanently
impaired to some degree because he
didn't have the time to save her first
job was either less than what they
wanted or maybe not at all and it took
later to get on the career trajectory
they were probably accumulating debt
along the way so you can appreciate that
some of those age cohorts just got dealt
a bad hand and they maybe permanently
would be higher but you're also seeing
the younger cohorts that were maybe in
high school or earlier during the great
recession also having an upward
trajectory of time at home so that's one
of the key uh analyses that we have to
go through is trying to figure out is
that temporary is it permanent
and looking at it at the different age
cohorts because there are different
factors as you go across as you look at
the youngest of 18 to 19 as an example a
lot more 18 and 19 year olds are
actually in high school now than there
used to be
either because they start later
intentionally or
different age brackets for different
states young adults going to college
obviously has an upward bias on that as
well so some of this stuff is actually
longer term positive for the economy and
you would think income growth but it can
be a headwind in the near term for
household formation and particularly
what you see is females
actually going to college at a much
higher rate than historically and the
share at home has been pressured most by
nails
so you can kind of get into that a
little bit but
um there are there are undertones to the
share at home that we think are more
structural we started to tear this apart
a bit more in 2016 2017 because that was
the point where we're looking at the
data and saying why is this not reversed
what is going on with this these age
cohorts so why
why would a male
choose to live with his parents for
longer versus a female who's like
bye-bye i'm leaving i'm going to college
i'm going to go you know at least i'm
going to follow the at least 500 miles
away from home rule
yeah and i think you see it in some of
the national stats right unemployment
rates for for males at the same
educational level that females in some
cases are are more pressured or
um for those without a college degree
male's kind of screaming more negatively
than females so you know i think it's uh
our sex being a little bit lazier and
probably playing too many video games to
matriculate up but oh my gosh i'm gonna
have to save this for my teenagers i'm
gonna clip what you just said anyways
sorry sorry to interrupt go on
um but something is is actually when we
dug into the factors or there are
different things people are speculating
on well is it just an unemployment thing
so if you can solve the unemployment
problem and solve the share at home but
we actually separated the cohorts
between those that are employed and
those are not either part-time or
full-time
and you actually saw even among
full-time employed young adults the
share at home had gone up over the the
last 10 years so it's almost a
willingness to be at home
whether that's because you're trying to
save for something or you just prefer to
be at home the parents prefer to have
them at home there certainly seems to be
less stigma around living with your
parents at an older age than there used
to be
um one of my colleagues brought up when
he was reading the report he said makes
me think about that old show get a life
um
you know it used to be you know
literally get a life get out of the
basement um but now it's not as much of
a stigma
um so the one thing that we found if
they're going through all these
different factors that actually was very
telling was the decline in marriage
rates
as the younger generations have either
foregone marriage altogether or decided
to get married later in life it's really
altered that trajectory to independence
and that's universal across the country
and that also wraps into less marriage
less lower fertility less likelihood of
having children so those two big
catalysts of marriage and children that
tend to
if you're not already on your own force
you on your own right those have been
under pressure so you can actually
explain some of this by pretty visible
factors of
less a lower less likelihood of getting
married less likely to have kids in a
higher propensity of going to college
particularly among females
is sort of pushing out that formation
and
as you get deeper into the age go or to
get closer to 40 some of the stuff
balances itself out but it does have a
steeper trajectory to it
well plus if you're
even if you're putting off marriage as
opposed to never getting married the
longer you put off marriage the fewer
children you're going to have so it you
know you feed into
people not needing to move up as they
once did because maybe a different size
home is appropriate uh for their family
the flip side of that though is
if all these parents have all these
adult kids living at home with them
um they're not
moving down
they're not downsizing they can't
downsize if you get your kids if
your kids are living with you right
exactly and you look at the different
age of course there's obviously a very
big
difference between a 20 the 20 to 24
year old shared home versus the 35 to 39
share at home
but all of those when you isolate them
individually all of those are up first
where it's been historically and for the
30 year old cohort i want to say it was
probably wrong closer to 10 and now it's
closer to 12 or 13
so it might not sound like a lot to have
that 200 300 basis point increase but
it's just it's a net negative to
household formation and it's something
that
a lot of clients are focused on when
they're asking the question because i
think there's still this embedded
expectation that well that's just that's
gravy that's tailwind that's yet to come
they're eventually thinking about but
when you balance a lot of these things
some of them structural like around
marriage in college those types of
things with some of the other stats that
we've talked about which you look at
death rates for young adults and a lot
of people haven't paid attention to this
but over the last 20 years death rates
for 20 to 40 year olds are up massive
yeah i um can you can you delve into
that a little bit because that was one
of the things that when i read that in
the report
you could have knocked me over with the
feather i was like you've got to be
kidding yeah yeah and i think that's the
reaction most people have because it's
just not talked about as much and it's
one of those you know again demographic
things that
isn't isn't front page news but if you
look at the change in depth rates across
cohorts just running every single age
year um
every age cohort up to 20 is down
significantly for that 23 year period
and then all the older age cohorts are
down quite a bit as well their life
longevity is improving healthcare
medical care etc
but that middle cohort is up massively
and you look at it on a chart and it
just stands out like a sore thumb
and it's the two leading causes are
overdoses and suicide so you think about
it it's really um
one of the doctors that present dr rosen
presented at our conference uh that you
were just at right um because of that
despair
and that's the hardest thing for them to
figure out and predict
um
i i don't know enough about why and what
you can speculate in a lot of different
directions but
obviously depression is kind of behind a
couple of those things in general yeah
whether that's financial depression
social depression whatever that might be
but obviously the account coordinates
not as happy as they once were or
seeking
um you know some type of solution
elsewhere
and it's resulting in that negatives and
there's small numbers in the grand
scheme of things so it's not as if
that's dry the overall deaths in our
country of massively or or the over the
overhang on household formation but it's
more of to me i'm looking at and say
well that's a that's a clue about how
this
cohort thinks and behave
and
thinking about somebody being at home is
also potentially intertwined with some
of those things as well sure so you
don't want to just dismiss it and say
well this is just an economic problem
that can be solved if you just give them
enough money write off their student
debt and give them a job
there's other factors
yeah somebody asked me recently you know
what's the most important aspect of
parenting and my answer was
you need to the most important thing you
can do as a parent is to give your
children independence dependents
because
you know that that way after you're gone
they've still got the ability to be
self-sustaining um
but as you said
we are living longer in general again
we've got the kids at home
ivy
has spoken quite a bit about aging in
place
so
i mean how has that affected
um
household formation or i should say
how has this been a support for the
housing market given again you've got
your kids in the basement cliche
and you're and you want to age in place
you want to stay in your home right
yeah that's a that's a good point
because
if you go back a handful of years
there's this perception and it might
even still exist but this perception
free pandemic that the baby boomers were
in their downsizing years that they were
going to be selling their single family
quote mcmansion
and moving down into some multi-family
unit maybe in the urban core so there
was a this rotation you had actually a
perception that well this is going to be
an inventory because you're gonna have
all these baby boomers selling their
single family homes and oh by the way
millennials don't even want simple
family homes anyway so that it sounds
crazy today especially after pandemic
but that was a very mainstream view oh i
i wrote an entire report about it that
said you know that you know it
if the stock market crashes and and you
know and
people's portfolios fall out of bed then
they're going to have to get rid of
their mcmansions and the millennium's
millennials don't want them so
exactly and and the reality of it is
when you when you you can you can't get
that at this exactly but you can get at
the size of these homes indirectly by
knowing when they were built and you
think about the average home in the 60s
70s being built was 1500 1600 1700
square feet it's not a very large home
when you think about it
the homes today i think the the toll
brothers mcmansion the i think that's a
minority a very very small piece of the
baby boomer
pie but what we were focused on more
than anything and this is why the
age-based analysis because becomes so
important is that
if you look at the percentage of 65 year
olds living in single family as an asset
class and so we always think about it
single-family multi-family traditional
multi-family two to four units and then
manufactured housing so we just think
about housing is those are your options
what's the market share of every age
the percentage of 65 year olds living in
single family has been going up
consistently over the last couple of
decades and even before that but
particularly during this controversial
period of the baby boomers so the
perception is they're sellers the
reality is they're consumers because
they are aging
they're staying that will be longer
they're working longer they're staying
as married couples longer because one of
them's not passing away and that keeps
people in place the vast majority of
people
of older cohorts you know it's sad to
say but they die in their single-family
home they don't want to leave
many cases they don't have the economics
to leave but in a lot of cases people
want to stay in their homes as long as
they can maintain it
and we add in the data so that the baby
boomer aspect has actually been very
favorable for single family over the
last couple of years it will continue to
be the last couple decades it will
continue to be this decade as well
there's actually a positive bias of that
aging
cohort for a single family
so um so lots of baby boomers staying in
their homes bigger homes than they were
several generations ago
are there are there going to be
implications because of affordability
in terms of um
of how many generations are going to be
living under one roof going forward i i
call it the italianization of of america
i mean is is that something is that a
phenomenon that you've picked up on and
one that we might see increase in time
i've seen a few articles here and there
um especially in the hispanic community
for example during the pandemic that
there are now more multi-generational
families in america than than there were
before
yeah yeah in fact you have to to
quantify and include in the analysis
because it is it has been happening in
the last couple of decades and there's
no reason to think that it'll stop
happening when you consider that the
growth of the population is largely
happening among minority cohorts
and then you think about the baby
boomers what you hear in some cases and
some of the builders have started to
design product around this is
multi-generational living not because of
an affordability issue but because they
actually want to be close to the
grandkids where it's a way for somebody
whose age that doesn't want to be in a
nursing home can still be close to their
family and be taken care of yet still
have their own independence so lennar is
one of the ones that has been very um
forefront on this on multi-generational
housing you know separate you know area
separate door entryway so some of those
things you have to take into account and
where you see it in the data
is if you exclude all the young kids
living at home and just look at all the
other adults and say well how many
adults are there in the average house
and you look at that across different
ways so you can say well let's just look
at married couples so we understand
we've isolated both the age and the
demographic circumstance there are more
adults in those households than there
used to be
and it's slowly creeping up and what
that essentially is is on the margins
it's household destruction
and housing less housing demand and when
you feel it back even further by race
what you find is um
blacks asians and hispanics all actually
have a higher percentage of adults per
household controlling for age
controlling for circumstance demographic
circumstance so if that's where the
growth of the population is you have a
mix impact alone
then on top of that the affordability
question starts to come in is it are
people doubling up and traveling up
because they want to or because they
have to i think there's an element of
both and the affordability element is
one that is probably going to get even
more attention as you keep rolling
forward especially after the last year
and a half where you've had so much
upward pressure on home prices and rents
well and you've also seen you know a
large withdrawal of workers of child
care workers
um so child care is obviously more
expensive than it's been so you know
being close to that grandparent uh
is
possibly not even really an option maybe
you need to have your parents close to
you uh
because of some of the developments that
we've seen and some of the changes that
we've seen in the composition of the
labor pool especially with millions of
moms who were forced to drop out of uh
out of the workforce because of virtual
learning and all this so i guess i guess
that brings us to
back to the pandemic
and how that has
amplified accelerated decelerated trends
that you had seen
in demographics and in housing
yeah
yeah the first thing um the thing that's
very obvious to anyone who's paying
attention is that you have a lot of
movement of households particularly
those looking for space whether that's
somebody who was in a multi-family unit
particularly urban core that wanted
space so that means moving to that
suburban area and a lot of the migration
data that you can look at whether it's
post office or some of the work that the
fed has done
it shows that the vast majority of urban
departures are to that same metro area
to the suburban areas
so it wasn't a situation of the new
yorker picking up and moving to austin
as much as it was the new yorker picking
up
jersey or long island or westchester and
i'm gonna i'm gonna interrupt you one
more time here zellman and associates
has done extraordinary work about what
you just mentioned and i think there's a
big misperception
out there that a lot of americans
uprooted and like moved halfway across
the country
yeah yeah i think there's and there's
certainly some of that especially among
younger cohorts that maybe um didn't
have a core base of where they were
living but especially when you think
about families there's no question that
there was that push to the suburbs and
you saw this explosion in a lot of these
suburban markets around urban areas
um so that was that that's very visible
i think it's debatable
how much of that was local versus across
state borders that's where maybe the
conversation gets more fun
but when you think about housing as a
whole what i think the pandemic really
did on the margin was it destroyed
incremental housing for household
formation
now most of the government data on this
topic is very volatile
there's a lot of surveys the government
produces that people use to try to
estimate household information which is
essentially the change in households
it's the incremental number of
households coming to market
and household means if you weren't a
household before and you became one on
your own that's household formation
that's you moving out of your parents
and being independent you moving away
from college and being independent or
two roommates splitting up and both of
them having their own that's all
household formation
if you think about the pieces during the
pandemic
young adults move back home
at a pretty rapid clip and while they've
started to reverse that
the share of young adults living at home
today is still higher than in 2019 same
time and that's across all the young
cohorts so young adults have actually
been a headwind in that regard
two million fewer young adults employed
today around 48 million than
pre-pandemic it was close to 50 million
so you can kind of understand on the
margin why you'd have more young adults
living at home it's hard to underwrite
that and say well that was a
catalyst for household formation so the
young piece i feel pretty confident and
that's kind of net household destruction
you think about deaths you obviously
have more people die than normal and if
you if you roll that through you had
about 600 000 excess debts
in 2020 you're probably going to be
closer to 450 500 this year
that's incrementally a three to four
hundred thousand household unit drag so
more people on average as you run that
through house headship rates understand
how those people are living and then
immigration immigration is typically a
huge impact on incremental population
growth and household demand and you know
that immigration was down massively in
2020 and is still down significantly
this year
so you take each of those pieces and you
say well
there's it's very hard to argue that you
actually created housing commander in
panama it's very easy to say you
destroyed it on the margin
not to say you didn't have household
formation but you had a lot less than
what a trend line wants
the perception is that well clearly the
pandemic was great for for housing and
household formation it's great for home
sales and it was great for
second homes but when we're trying to
get a core demographically driven
primary and it was actually okay so so
what you just said you should probably
stop and repeat because that is at the
core of
your analysis what differentiates
your philosophy your view and it's just
hard data but just just repeat it one
more time because it's so important
yeah yeah household formation which is
primary housing demand we could talk
about secondary demand second house
separately but core housing demand is we
would think of it slowed dramatically
because of the pando every every
component of what drives incremental
demand went the wrong way
and and this year you'll still have you
stop the drive from immigration you saw
the drag from excessive deaths the young
adults are starting to reverse the
headwind from last year like i said
they're still higher than 2019 but they
are starting to unbundle back so that's
been healthy and particularly on the
multi-family side in our minds it's
probably the biggest catalyst for why
multi-family has had a great revival
this year especially in the urban core
but you kind of have to sit there in a
lot of cases and say as people kind of
debate this where are we in the housing
cycle
and i've gotten to this point where it's
almost this
uber cycle still in front of us you kind
of rewind the clock and say let's go
back to the end of 19 and where were we
all talking about the housing market at
that point how's home price appreciation
was solid but it was actually
decelerating it's the slowest year for
home price appreciation on our numbers
since 2011.
the whole cycle and rent growth wasn't
much better home improvement spending
growth was the same it was the worst
year of the recovery it was only three
percent so the consumer wasn't you know
drastically leaning into housing
they were okay it was a it was a very
solid situation but it wasn't this um
this backdrop that you'd sit there and
argue there's this just overwhelming man
that have to satisfy
so you kind of take all the things that
happened during the pandemic from the
home sales side and a lot of that was
driven by people who
were looking for a second home or really
mortgage rate driven to upgrade
particularly people that already had a
home and you understand the whole lot of
multi-family in a single family so you
have all these factors for less to
really drive single family demand at a
point when
um and drive a home price appreciation
but it doesn't mean that that's now the
new point to extrapolate from i think
you almost have to acknowledge that
there's this bubble up factor that
happened it was real
we know why it happened but now let's
take a step back and say okay as we
think about 22 23 24
did we pull a lot of demand forward now
we have to think about how we pay that
back or is this the new paradigm and
that's where i think we differ with a
lot of folks that are simply taking this
this data and now underwriting is really
aggressive pent up demand lack of
supplier
and that's not that that's not what you
foresee
know and and the one one of the best
charts i think in the report is one
where we simply are just showing
household formation by decade mm-hmm
and if you go back to and i'll be sure
and share some of these graphs so that
we can flash them up on the screen yeah
and if you go back we have this data
really forever but if you look at the
1990s they had about 13 and a half
million households formed
and then from 2000 to 2010 the reported
number i think was 11 2
and then this most recent decade was 10
1. so just factually stepping back and
looking at those data you'd say okay
that's a step function down each decade
and then they say well 2010 was a really
bad time to be doing the decennial
census because it was in the middle of
very elevated unemployment so that would
have probably been a drag on household
formation at that time that snapshot in
time
and so we actually tried to estimate
what would that drag what if we didn't
have the elevated unemployment how many
more households would we have had so you
adjust for that cyclically and we think
you probably were closer to 11 9 high
11's in the 2000 2010 period and then
from 2010 to 20 because you've raised
the base now your sub 10 this most
recent decade so no matter how you look
at it you've got this very clear step
function lower
and yet most people are starting their
process of well how much how many homes
we need to build we'll say well we've
always built a million and a half just
look at the long-term trend line go back
to 1970 that's what we've done
and yet they're not acknowledging that
the core tenant of new construction
which is household formation has been
falling throughout that period so why
anchor yourself to some historical
figure on supply when the demand side
has clearly changed from where it was
and yet
the the histrionics of a recent report
from the national association of
realtors
saying we're you know we've got a 6.8
million home deficit over the next
decade you know it's just just
absolutely cats dogs falling from the
sky just mass disaster
um
and that i think that that is the the
conventional wisdom right now
yeah and i've read that report i'm sure
you have and a lot of people have and it
was a third party consultant that was
hired to do it i could have saved him a
few dollars i think on that one
i didn't like my message as much but it
would have saved savings money but you
read that report and you know i'm always
careful to criticize other people's work
i think everyone's obviously got some
intellectual capacity behind it but
you read that report and the entire
thing is talking only about supply how
many units did we build how many did we
then build this last decade and let's
compare those two numbers i think
population and population growth might
have been mentioned in the 30 page
document twice
so how do you how do you try to estimate
what you need to build
if you don't have a process to estimate
the demand side
it's it's
it's
just mathematical insanity as i
mentioned earlier it's it's hard to to
kind of even win an argument without
going through that process and and
there's some others out there that have
actually approached it in a way more
similar to how we would approach it and
get to numbers that are not as
aggressive as that nar report but still
multiple millions of shortfall freddie
mac's my everybody's sites are close to
four million it's a more thoughtful
process building from from household
to the household level but they are you
need a structurally higher vacancy rate
than you've seen historically so we need
more empty homes which is why we need to
build more
which i don't think we agree with but at
least it's a structural argument that
mathematically makes sense
but you don't need many of these to be
out there for that to then be the media
story and then once it's the media story
then it's the company's story and once
it's their story then they just invest
in that way
well so
um we have seen
quite a bit of home building
uh
of late
um
are there areas where we
have risk of being over supplied and are
there areas
where you see
great big deficits areas of housing that
have not been built that should have
been built
yeah i think there's obviously always a
that geographic undertone to this and
that's one of the things that came out
of this report is when you
look at we actually looked at nine
states that we call them slow states
where they had
never achieved five percent or greater
population growth and for the last five
decades so they have been persistently
slow growing states and you can you know
guess some connecticut new york illinois
kind of rust belt northeast older states
and we looked at
how their new production has trended
over time and not surprisingly as you've
slowed population growth solid household
formation the number of new supply
coming to market has dropped falling
dramatically down anywhere from 60 to 70
percent from the 1970s depending on how
you want to think about the overbuilt
situation
so that's just that's just the reality
in those in those states and that's kind
of what the country is is moving towards
with a slower growth environment um if
you look at the vacancy rate in those
states however it was 9.1
the vacancy rate for the whole country
was 9.7
so it's not a situation where
that slow growth environment led to an
excessive amount of homes and then in
the rest of the country we've absorbed
all the homes you've seen the same
dynamics play out because as weak as
those areas are
demographically who doesn't know that
who's not sitting there
is there anyone arguing that they should
go build in illinois and michigan and
connecticut because there's this massive
opportunity of growth
no everybody every every incremental
decision that you see is oh we're going
to go grow in the smiles
we're going to grow in the southwest and
southeast and when everybody says the
same thing then it's no longer just well
i have to understand the demand side but
i also have to understand the supply
side and how that's going to match up
and i think that's where you start
worrying about it's not so much that
you're not going to have above average
growth in some of these states but it's
well what level of growth are they
expecting
and supplying towards
and just like at the national level if
you're anchored in history and you build
to that you're going to overbuild so you
actually worry everywhere
because if everywhere is anchored to
history and everywhere is slowing which
it is even in the high growth parts of
the country the household formation
you're going to see this decade is going
to be down significantly from what you
saw in the 70s 80s 90s because the
demographics of the aging population
that's a national thing yes you get a
better immigration and you get
cross-country flows that help but you're
still dealing with a lot of these same
dynamics young adults at home
over generation aging there's a lot of
factors immigration impacting
incremental number of adults per
household so it is something that you're
seeing across the country
and from a supply side the other aspect
is
if you take the different components so
home building single family for sale
single family for rent which has become
a explosive area and then multi-family
even thinking through the impacts of the
pandemic as we've mentioned if you had
to pick a part of housing that would
have been that negative multifamily
would be you know that part especially
the urban poor
and yet multi-family permits and starts
are exploding higher as well so there's
not
there's really no conservatism across
the developers and right now
because it takes time for the stuff to
become a market plus the consumer is so
engaged in the housing there's nothing
that's going to disrupt them in the next
probably six or 12 months they're always
going to lean harder than they probably
should
so you don't have this you know red flag
that something's just going to fall off
in the next six or 12 months
but as people are putting their
investments in the ground for
development builders single family and
multi-family if you're out of 12 months
18 months and they think you can build 2
million units a year and still be having
to have a deficit because everybody's
telling them that and really you need to
be building a million 3 million for a
year then at some point you run into
that you can't over build forever and
and for us it's that incremental
decision on development where
our research is kind of saying this is
later cycle you probably want to be
de-risking whereas most of the industry
is saying we just lasted through that
recession now it's now it's investment
time because everybody's telling us
there's a housing change
so i i was i was kind of intrigued
though because you you wrote about and
this is you know you hear about the
affordability afford affordability
crisis you're right harvard does some
really good work
um on on on households that are spending
40 50 percent of their take home
on housing
is there an area that has been
underbuilt
well i think everybody everybody would
appreciate if we could bring affordable
housing to market and it's a it's a
topic that i think will only gain more
mind share as you move forward
but let's talk about what is getting
built because
there's a reason why affordable is not
because it can't economically work for
the for the landowner and the builder
you need some type of government
incentive or some type of partnership to
encourage that type of building the idea
that somebody can
build a new unit that meets the
monthly payment capabilities of the
middle income cohort it's very difficult
with land costs where they are in
construction cars where they are so
you know i don't i don't mean to be like
dismissive of this idea but i think
everybody would like to drive a bmw too
and but you can't build a bmw no matter
how you try
that's going to meet that price point
and take single family bill for rent as
an example we just did a big report on
that as well
and there's this perception well that's
affordable housing that's the solution
because you're bringing a rental product
to somebody who can't afford a home the
monthly payment on most of that product
is 2 000 or more
and you think about somebody who's in a
multi-family two-bedroom rental they're
probably closer to a thousand a rent so
what are you really solving from an
affordability standpoint with that
product
it's not hitting at the core of the
market um so i outside of the
government's involvement to or some type
of government incentive to defray the
costs
i just don't know how you're going to
encourage the private market to build
something that they can't make any money
right
and and the other thing i would say on
this is it's trying to figure out the
best way to present this in a research
report but
when you think about housing is almost
the catch-all beating bag for
affordability because it's the biggest
part of people's budget right um but
what about we flip the coin the other
way and say
instead of calling an affordability
crisis for housing maybe it's a health
care crisis because health care costs
are up so much and even people's
paycheck maybe it's an educational
crisis because educational costs are
cost money it's an income crisis because
you're not driving income growth enough
to keep up with the cost of materials
and land everything else that goes into
housing why does housing have to be the
residual
it's only the residual because it's so
big and it's the biggest part of
people's paycheck but i would guess if
you look at the monthly payment on a
house over a long period of time and
granted this interest rate driven but
it's still it's the cash flow going out
the door for the homeowner that probably
hasn't changed that much relative to cpi
at least prior to the pandemic
what has changed is that the incomes
aren't keeping up and that savings
aren't keeping up for people to afford a
down payment so i actually think you
could twist this a lot of different ways
i think housing is unjustly kind of
vilified a lot of times that well it's a
housing problem
it's just the output that's telling you
that they don't have enough money to pay
for something more than what they're
living in now
interesting
um
so
how does how can instances were in
inside the beltway for a few minutes uh
how does immigration policy
affect uh affect housing what role is
played
is played there
i think historically
it hasn't been as necessary to focus as
much on it because you had such good
organic growth in the economy
the population but i think it's turned
into a point where it's going to be the
utmost factor moving forward because as
i mentioned the domestic population is
going to be shrinking by the end of the
decade
so everything every ounce of population
growth
is going to come from immigration
and if you don't have a policy around it
then how can in a policy of
not just a social policy but an economic
policy i think you have to start
thinking about immigration in economic
terms not just social terms because if
you start shrinking a population you
start shrinking the amount of things
people need particularly housing think
about just as big of an engine is it's
housing is for the for the economy if
you put pressure on that because you
don't need more housing because you're
not growing population you don't need
more cars because you're not growing the
population you start thinking about the
ripple effect right it's an economic
problem and
the challenge i think you have is we use
some data from the pew center research
center on this is there's become more of
a polarization of immigration views
between democrats and republicans and
it's turned into a political hot button
and
now that it's in that arena
you worry that it'll never be an
economic issue even though it should be
one
but
you also kind of think about it from the
supply side of labor here you are
complaining about most industries about
lack of labor and some of that social
programs admittedly but there's going to
be
um you know there could be a solution on
both ends if you had a policy around
immigration bring certain types of labor
here then you solve that problem
alongside
creating demand
so there's
probably shouldn't speak out of terms
i've done a ton of economic research on
some of these things but it just
intuitively makes sense that if you have
a policy around immigration you can
contribute to the population growth
as our country has forever right that's
how we were built that's how
our population is my grandparents my
grandparents came over on ellis island
from italy so yeah sure oh exactly and
and today's uh you know polish americans
irish americans italian americans were
one day thought of as troublesome for
that you know cohort of time but they
came here they were labor manual labor
they worked hard and now there's no
differentiation on that you know we're
living here so
it seems to be it could it it's a
now is the time though because you
realize that
some of the stuff that we're talking
about isn't going to really bite you for
eight years ten years on one level you'd
sit there and say we'll solve that
another day
but at the same time if you want to
solve it by the end of the decade you
kind of have to start talking about some
of that stuff now
so
what happens when this discussion does
not occur what
what what what lessons can we learn from
japan
yeah we used um so we used japan as a
case study in this report less so about
the economic implications and more so to
prove that point of
a slower growth economy and a slower
growth household means you put pressure
on housing that's exactly what we've
seen in japan
where the population growth is now
negative but it was slowing for the last
several decades the same reasons is here
aging population weak fertility the
difference between there and here is
there's no immigration very limited
so they are having a hard time
offsetting and you look at the
projections from others you're looking
at 20 30 40 percent type declines in
japanese population over the next plus
years so they're on a slope that's
pretty difficult to reverse and you can
imagine what that means for extra
housing as more people
die you know and open up capacity of
which is not needed then you're just
going to have continuously higher
vacancy rates um
so the domestic side i think you can
actually have a bit of a lead time
because what's happened in japan is
happening earlier than it's happened
here but it's happening the exact same
way so i think they give you a very good
transparency to what to expect on the
domestic population site from uh from a
housing site it's interesting thing i've
learned after doing this is in japan
it's much more common to knock down a
very little ball
so somebody does not there's a cultural
dynamic of not wanting to live in a home
with somebody else living in so very
livable homes historically have been
knocked down and they just rebuilt so
existing homes actually depreciate over
time in japan
so their build their number of homes
they build is actually much higher for
their level of households than here so
some people might take a
false positive out of what they see out
of japan obviously that's not going to
be the circumstance here so i think
there's a lot to learn in the
interesting aspect of it for me is that
you have some lead time to learn from it
it's right in front of us there's a
blueprint for what happens if you don't
have immigration and your domestic
population start slowing or decline you
know exactly what's going to happen
that's the case but our country could
through immigration policy change that
trajectory that japan
um
so
the tv show friends kept coming to mind
when i was reading through some of the
parts of the of the report i i hadn't
realized that uh there are so many more
roommates today than there used to be
yeah
yeah and some of that is uh the way i
was phrasing this before the pandemic
was um
i don't think that young adults were on
a different longer term path in prior
generations as far as getting married
having children moving to the suburbs we
actually were seeing that play out if
they got to that point in their life
what we were seeing happening is what i
would say is they're being young longer
staying young longer
unwed which means no kids longer
enjoying their 20s longer and that might
be because they're starting
their career later after going to
college later or other factors
but it was a steeper slope to go from
multifamily to single family the trigger
was happening later in life
and i think that that's that's going to
be with us you know through this decade
i think the
it's very unlikely that you're going to
start to see marriage rates pick up or
based on just what you've seen
historically from some of these age
goals or fertility rates first
and what that means is if you're going
to be younger longer you're going to
live
like you're younger longer which is more
likely to be roommate not necessarily
but more likely to have a roommate more
likely to live alone perhaps more likely
to be urban than suburban for that
extended period of time until you get to
the point of family orientation or
needing more space for a family so that
again is back where
as we tear all this stuff apart by age
cohort some of this just kind of stares
back at you with the data
because you can see this happening over
time
and it matches up with with intuitively
what we see from our friends and family
and we're colleagues and so forth we
understand why
so um
talk talk a little bit about the
the home building
industries perception of
the supply that's needed
and what you actually what your
calculations have uh drawn out
yeah and to think about this in maybe
smooth terms because you have a cyclical
element to it um and what we're trying
to do is say well we know we can't time
the cyclical piece especially around
mortgage rates but we can certainly
understand that that will smooth itself
out
so our math is that you have about 10
million households formed over the
decade that's going to be the core
driver of new construction
and then on top of that you've got a
vacancy contribution which is
essentially the same as the stock grows
you'll have an incremental vacant unit
growing with it just to maintain the
vacancy rate for the whole whole country
and then you'll have what you have to
replace whatever you knock down either
you knock it down intentionally or you
lose a home to fire or tornado or
obsolescence you know that as you take
that unit out of the stock then you have
to put a new one back in to replace it
so we go through different uh estimates
on how we how we think about those two
pieces admittedly those are harder to
model than the household side from my
perspective
but you use history as a guy and you use
a couple different checks top down
bottoms up and so we assume we estimate
that you need about
1.35 million new units based on
normalized demand so 10 million or
1 million per year household formation
equals about 135 on new construction
if you look at that over the course of
that's smoothed out over the course of
the decade now the the math most others
would be looking at would be
well we've always built a million and a
half homes so let's just assume history
will continue and will mean reverb
and then because we didn't build enough
homes last decade right you've heard
their math then now we need to build a
million half but we need to make up for
this shortfall and that's where the nar
as an example if you have a 6.8 million
shortfall or even if it's 5 million
it takes you 10 years to burn it off
you've got an extra half a million per
year and all of a sudden it's 2 million
a year so i think that report literally
says you could build 2 million a year
for the next decade and still be short
housing
and you know there's different
iterations of that math that other
people are looking at but i think
the development community as a whole is
looking at it and saying
i don't know what what the needs are i
just know it's higher than now and i
know we've got this huge safety net of a
deficit that's their perception right so
it's a little bit of build build build
and we'll figure it out later
and what they're queuing off of more
than anything and i get this question a
lot but they're queuing off of the
current market they're saying well home
prices are going up insanely rents are
going up how can't there be a deficit
there must be a deficit the market's
telling us there's a deficit and so
they they listen they see the data and
the capital is cheap the capital is
plentiful so it all
brews together for this you know
confidence on the supply side and that's
we're seeing that
so um
talk a little bit about mobility going
forward
my former employer the federal reserve
during the heat of the financial crisis
uh we actually had internal discussions
about
what will the effect of these ultra-low
four percent at the time four percent
mortgage rates it's gonna stunt mobility
going forward because nobody's ever
gonna want to leave that that mortgage
rate and now we've obviously seen i mean
i think 30 the 30-year fixed got
what was it it was even below the three
percent line
yeah just checked back above it um but
yeah it was
the way that we look at it is um
you know there's this uh if you think
about where prevailing rates are and
where people's existing rates are
the bigger that spread is the more there
is an incentive to do something whether
that's refinance into your existing
asset and lower your carry costs or to
move entirely and use that
that arbitrage on the rate to
essentially upgrade and maintain your
monthly payment
a lot of people do right usually they
rate as a way of upgrading
and so not surprisingly there's a
significantly high correlation between
the spread of prevailing and outstanding
rates and housing turnover and re-buy
activity
and the
current period is starting to
shrink because of all the activity but
if you look at the end of last year
since 1990 i think i want to say either
three or four of the six
most favorable quarters of spread
were this period during the pandemic
so the spread was so wide so quick
that you can understand why it
incentivized so many people to act and i
think a lot of the movement during the
pandemic
had nothing to do with pandemic reasons
it had everything to do with it was a
good time to move because it was cheap
capital and it was a good time to
upgrade no different than you see in any
other housing cycle good or bad so as
you look forward
if rates go up especially rates were to
go up meaningfully turnover will slow
dramatically in our opinion i i don't
think that's debatable when you've seen
it every other period of of a bump in
rates you see
and there's a reason to understand why
to your point if it's no longer if you
no longer have the economic incentive to
refi or move then you don't
and the only reason you do is because
you have some forced decisions
our view on rates is we have no idea and
you know we've been as long as we've
been at this i think people have been
expecting mortgage rates to go up at
some point and they just keep going down
which gets back to like your area of
expertise on where are we truly with
economic growth once you get past the
stimulus
higher rates and inflation trends during
all those things but so our view is if
rates were to go higher it absolutely
impacts the market slows down things
particularly price appreciation
um the other thing on mobility that i
think is interesting is
in a lot of cases i think work from a
home is being perceived as actually
increasing mobility moving people around
more
and while i think that's relevant for
some parts of the employment base
you have to also look at how many moves
housing moves were historically driven
by corporate relocations or by company
you got a new job that wasn't in the
same area right
moved to atlanta where corporate
headquarters moved and
you look at um
large
long distance moves during the pandemic
last year i think this is going to be
the same thing they're down massively
because you didn't have to relocate
relocation moves are probably going to
be down significantly you could actually
argue that work from home will pressure
mobility
for especially the older cohorts because
they'll take that new job and work from
home you're taking your job anywhere in
that mode so it'll be interesting to see
how that tug of work plays out because i
don't think it's all necessarily work
from home necessarily is 100 beneficial
in mobility
um
do you think we will see any element of
a reversal
of the migration out of cities
and wha
what are the implications uh
both on the single family and the
multi-family side because
you also have opinions about
the potential for multi-family to be uh
going down this same path of
for the oversupply family side i don't
know i don't think there'll be a
reversal
mostly because i think what we did was
we pulled forward people who are going
to buy
in the suburbs anyway
this with a lot of the young adult data
if you look at the pre-pandemic trend of
25 to 29 year old households you had
about five percent were buying each year
percentage of households buying a home
primary home
and that jumped to 78
for 20 and 21. so you had this very
clear trend line which is a slow and
steady demographic thing happening as
people got married have kids they were
buying you know share of them or buying
homes and that spike and then the same
thing happened for 30 to 34
and the interesting thing is if you tear
apart 20 20 transactions the strongest
growth was among the youngest awards
yeah the oldest cohorts were actually
down in transactions versus 19. the
older folks that weren't were afraid of
gold but didn't want to move didn't want
to deal with
it actually didn't move so this was a
young person's trade that was happening
predominantly in 2020
and those are people that probably would
have gotten 22 23 24 i see it in my own
community where the amount of families
that moved out of manhattan very young
kids
that said yeah we were probably going to
do it at some point but this forced our
hand
and their kids are preschool and they
were previously thinking well we would
have done it when they got to elementary
school and so you hear these anecdotes
across the country and you can
understand why
um so i think you're you probably just
pull pull them forward i don't think
they're going to reverse works um now
the multi-family side is interesting
because you pulled them out of
multi-family buildings
and now you sit there and say okay well
how do we replenish that
you have to replenish that with the
younger
uh cohort who was living at mom and
dad's whoever's course or who's coming
out of college so i think you've got
this replenishment period where you just
have to refill those buildings with
younger folks
and there's probably going to be this
this soft spot for a while because what
the pandemic also did is it pushed
people back home is it didn't
allow for that normal organic coupling
married soon to be kids so i think
you're going to have the soft spot of
the you know let's say the next
generation of single family buyers is
probably going to have a wide spot in it
and so you can replenish some of that
with all the folks
here before um risk of multi-family
supply just like the others
it depends on what you're underwriting
to if you're convinced that there's so
many millennials out there that you can
build as much as you want buildings will
be full
you know that just carries you back to
the demographic piece and and i do think
that the urban multi-family will
actually have a pretty good relative
decade of demand because you are keeping
people young longer
and demographically the millennials are
helpful in some respect to multi-family
but also just the way people are living
is somewhat helpful
but it depends on again back to whether
it's going to be
a good sector to be and will have a lot
to do with the spy side how it matches
up
so my final question because this is
what surprised me the most i i i went
back and i read it and i reread it and i
re-read it
um there's going to be more kids living
at home
in 2030 than there are today
a higher percentage how does that happen
because you wouldn't think that it could
go much higher
yeah
and i i think it's again one of the more
debated points i have with clients is
again back to the assumption that same
assumption we have you know and i'm very
upfront with clients like we assume the
same thing you're talking about now 10
years ago and we were dead wrong
and we were thinking about it a lot
through the decade about why we were
wrong and trying to understand why we
were wrong and that's where i go back to
how much of this is explainable and how
much of it it's not that the the impact
from declining marriage rates and
fertility rates and the fact that you've
got a lot of young adults that are
getting educated which also means that
they're more likely to end up in an
urban location a suburban location or i
shouldn't even say suburban rural
location so the rule to urban in our
country there's a very interesting chart
we had in our presentation
which was you have
53 percent of the counties in this
country
had a population decline from 2010 to 20
53 of the counties in the country and it
is across the country you might in your
head be thinking rust belt northeast 143
of those were in texas
so it's a rule to urban situation in our
country and this is very true across the
globe as you go rural to urban you have
fewer kids and you live differently so
this dynamic of
young adults going up some of it we
think is just structurally because of
the differences in the demographics
principally marriage and college
education going on for females
um some of it though goes back to things
that we couldn't explain last decade
that it's hard to think it's going to
get much better whether it's
affordability on the housing side or
back to the social dynamics that are
going on young adults decorates up a lot
again leaves us thinking differently
about this isn't just an economic
problem it's a social problem
and so i think we we sort of reverse
course a bit to say
there's no sign of this slowing
or what we've seen the increase that
we've modeled for 2030 versus 2020 is
not dramatic it's a lot less than what
we saw last decade and it is debatable
so we gave some sensitivities as well to
say well if you don't think that will be
the case let's say
you think it's actually going to be
consistent with where it was in 2020
then that worked out to be about an
extra half a million households over the
course of the decade
if you think it gets even better than
2020 then that's incremental again so
right you could really bullish with it
and say we think this is the structural
change young adults are going to reverse
course we're actually going to see it
decline not just into 2020's level but
all the way back to 2010 we'd get you
another 2 million
so you can underwrite something you know
much more optimistic but at the same
time
are we going to keep getting fooled and
hopeful that this is going to reverse
course
um that's that's where we wanted to bend
more to the conservative side well if i
if i could if i could give give one
suggestion it would be uh for for your
next major analysis it would kind of be
the role that autumn automation in the
workforce is going to play going forward
with these younger individuals i'm i'm
intrigued that we've seen several
consecutive weeks of rising unemployment
claims and you're saying to yourself
wait a minute there's all these job
openings out there well i think i think
if there's one lesson that we'll learn
in hindsight about the pandemic it might
have to do with the fact that a lot of
jobs were simply made redundant on a
permanent basis so
obviously innovation is going to be very
critical going forward but it will play
into your world so i will i'll look
forward to uh i'll look forward to
planting that seed so to speak so you
can have a point because like i
mentioned even just looking at the jobs
48 million jobs in that cohort it was
50. so as much as you know the financial
markets in the housing market and the
ownership markets have improved you know
for that young adult cohort you can
understand why it's not as rosy as it
was everything exactly exactly well um
listen i'm this this was fascinating uh
um
we had a great long talk i hope
everybody
learned something and the beauty of this
discussion is that nobody's talking
about it so um i i really look forward
to you educating a lot of people on this
subject so we can start to think more
rationally about housing moving forward
so thank you so much today for your time
i really appreciate it dennis oh i had a
pleasure and i enjoyed talking through
it and i think you're right i think it
would be very topical for a while and
we'll be very interested to see it play
out
well we'll see you next time thanks much
and you thought demographics was boring
material
wasn't that interesting i mean we're
going to have more kids living with
their parents in 2030 than we do today i
mean just try and wrap your head around
that uh and you know if i could say
anything i would encourage all of us to
you know if you're not married go out
and get married procreate
you know form a household uh so that we
can help with with the future economic
growth
uh in this country if you found dennis's
interview interesting uh remember that i
also have interviewed his co-founder ivy
zellman uh several months back so look
back at that interview as well if you if
you want to hear more about housing but
less from a demographic angle and i'll
actually also be interviewing her again
pretty soon in new york so look forward
to that and thank you for tuning in to
this episode of down the middle this is
danielle dimartino booth thank you
[Music]